[Música]
bienvenidos a ello soy de france24 un
tema recurrente en este programa es el
acoso callejero
nuestra tarea es desaprender que el
acoso haga parte de la normalidad en el
espacio público especialmente para las
mujeres por eso hoy nos acompañará la
mona soy yo una youtuber colombiana que
se dedica a la concientización del
machismo y a construir campañas por el
feminismo junto a esta feminista está
valentín a enciso y ellas realizarán el
proyecto agarrate la falda un vídeo
performance que rompe con el temor de
usar faldas en la calle para impulsar
esta iniciativa que mejor que ver el
vídeo que realizaron aquí lo tenemos
[Música]
como visto lo que ha visto
mujer de salvamento
sólo son tumbas más
pero no necesitas
y estoy solita amado pocas
[Música]
el tema
mi cuerpo se respeta se quiere que me la
meta
si están muy altas
[Música]
ya pasó de moda no me importa lo que
pienses tú estabas
[Música]
la rosa camacho
está con nosotros lucía beltrán chamorro
la mona soy yo así la conocen al menos
sus seguidores en youtube bienvenida a
ellas hoy gracias por estar con nosotros
hola qué tal muchísimas gracias por la
invitación bueno lucía las mujeres no
queremos piropos en la calle no nos
gusta eso no es halago eso se llama
acoso ese es el mensaje de su vídeo
cuéntenos de ese tema si es verdad
realmente nosotras hicimos con valentina
enciso hicimos una investigación en
nuestras redes sociales queríamos hacer
como unas estadísticas para saber
realmente cuáles eran esos temas que más
nos afectaban a nosotras como mujeres y
el tema más recurrente ha sido el acoso
callejero obviamente han sido muchísimos
otros pero el que nosotras más pudimos
notar era este el hecho de poderlo salir
a la calle como lo decimos en la canción
con una falda a nosotras nos atemorizó
un montón salir a la calle a las diez de
la noche solas ese temor que tenemos en
la calle nosotras lo vivimos a diario y
nos da muchísimo pánico así que
queríamos enfrentar una canción para que
se vuelva aún agárrate la falda para
estar
contra el acoso callejero o incluso
también agárrate la falda para estar en
contra de los roles de género
establecidos bueno justamente para ella
iba porque agarrarse la falda fue el
término que ustedes eligieron para esta
campaña que además no viene de la nada
sino de todo un proceso de formación que
ustedes realizaron unos talleres unos
fondos que les dieron para hacer este
activismo
exactamente nosotras nos ganamos un
concurso que se llama creadoras camp que
es un campamento virtual en el que
nosotros íbamos a tener clases durante
dos semanas sobre feminismo dirigido por
catalina ruiz navarro por it amarilla y
por un montón de colectivo pues gigante
de mujeres feministas entonces nosotras
ganamos esto en latinoamérica fuimos 13
y cada una tenía este estímulo o esta
beca en la que cada una hacía un
proyecto diferente tenemos podcasting
talks instagram estévez y nosotras
decidimos hacer un videoclip musical con
respecto al nombre de agarrate la falda
pues es muy bonito porque han escuchado
la frase de ponte los pantalones o quien
tiene los pantalones en la relación o
agárrate los pantalones nosotros
quisimos darle un transfondo a esto y
decir agárrate la falda como un sinónimo
de que la falda tampoco es debilidad y
que la falda no tiene que ver solamente
con mujeres sino que también puede
utilizarlo en los hombres por eso es que
nuestro vídeo todas las personas que
están en el vídeo tienen una falda
incluidos hombres y mujeres
bueno y hay otro tema del que usted
habla constantemente en sus redes
sociales y es porque necesitamos las
mujeres aprobación masculina y eso tiene
mucho que ver con el tema del acoso
callejero hay algo de esa cultura
machista en lo que vivimos las mujeres
cada vez que habitamos o que transitamos
por las ciudades
es cierto la razón hay algo que se llama
la aprobación masculina y es que desde
pequeñas y nuestra propia cultura nos
enseña que tenemos que hacer cosas para
agradarle al hombre entonces he conocido
varias mujeres que esto lo tiene tan
normalizado que dicen como hay hoy de
pronto no me hicieron ningún piropo será
que hoy no estaba bonita pero realmente
esto va mucho más allá de un si estás
linda o no si no de un abuso de poder y
de una desigualdad de poder de como yo
si puedo decirte cosas y tú no entonces
yo me siento en una ventaja frente a ti
eso es la idea contra el acoso callejero
pero por supuesto que está demasiado
normalizado y nosotras lo toleramos no
es que nos gusten los que nos agrade
salir a la calle y que cualquier
desconocido pues nos pueda hablar o nos
pueda saludar si no es más el hecho de
tolerar nos como ya estoy tan
acostumbrada pero que porque estás
acostumbrada no significa que algo sea
correcto
bueno hay un tema y es que dirían
algunos que nosotros lo permitimos y que
en ese sentido es nuestra
responsabilidad de que sucedan este tipo
de acosos callejeros pero también está
la otra parte que es el peligro que
enfrentamos cuando nos defendemos del
acoso callejero podemos llegar a ser
víctimas de agresiones más fuertes
emocionales o incluso se pueden ir a lo
físico
exactamente por eso es muy importante
crear políticas y que cambiar
estructuralmente este tipo de
situaciones legalmente es decir el
cercano barrio hay una construcción y la
construcción dice en esta obra estamos
en contra del acoso callejero entonces
este tipo de situaciones también los
pone a nosotros como una ventaja y decir
como oye mira que esto no está tan bueno
y uno como mujer sabe de quién
defenderse y de quién no en la mayoría
de los casos no siempre pero muchas
veces nosotros salimos y decimos oye qué
te pasa respétame y ahí inmediatamente
el acosador se silencia pero hay otras
veces como tú lo dices que estamos en
peligro que ellos tienen esta ventaja
del poder en la cual cree que como somos
débiles tú somos mujeres que pues
estamos solas indefensas en la calle
pues quién va a ayudarnos entonces cree
en esta situación y nos ponen a nosotras
en peligro por eso también es bueno
casi siempre que estas cosas sucedan lo
que nosotros queramos responder que haya
más personas como que no estemos tan
solas totalmente es una situación muy
complicada que nosotros vivimos
diariamente y en cada lugar en cada
distrito y en cada lugar de la región es
diferente si una cosa es el piropo
callejero en la ciudad otra cosa es como
en tierra caliente donde la ropa también
se presta para esto lastimosamente
entonces es como por eso en la canción
nosotros decimos no importa si tenemos
falta si está alta o está abajo lleva a
medias o lleva mallas es que la ropa
tampoco debería ser una invitación a que
me faltes al respeto y ahí nos vamos a
hablar de la masculinidad como la hemos
concebido y de esas nuevas
masculinidades que deberíamos promover
desde que educamos a los hijos y bueno
quien no tiene un amigo o un familiar
que uno usted ha visto que esta persona
va y ejerce acoso callejero contra otra
mujer entonces hasta qué punto es
nuestro deber también frenar esas cosas
pues desde casa y desde los conocidos
si es muy cierto sin embargo um a mí no
me parece bien que uno vaya a atacar a
alguien más porque muchas personas
crecen creyendo que está bien y si tú le
estás arruinando a alguien y diciéndole
oye qué te pasa se le estás atacando lo
que vas a causar es que la otra persona
se sienta atacada y no quiera cambiar y
quiera seguir ahí manifestándose pero en
cambio si tú le hablas y le dices él
porque esta situación no es tan correcta
y le haces a entender algo bien como de
verdad no estás haciendo sentir mal de
verdad no estoy incomodando de verdad
esto no es agradable pues la otra
persona lo va a entender si nosotros
tenemos a alguien cerca que lo hace y
podemos y podemos decirle oye para un
momento reflexiona ante esta situación y
dime si realmente te parece correcto
seguir haciéndolo y pues la persona
obviamente podría cambiar esos de hecho
lo que yo trato de hacer en mis redes
sociales sembrar esa semilla de la duda
durante la visualización del vídeo que
veíamos hace un momento me llamó mucho
la atención una de las líneas de la
canción y dice no quiero que me lo metas
entonces es muy directo tan directo como
cualquier mujer podría sentirse
identificada con el términos que le han
dicho por la calle y quisiera hablar de
eso de enfrentar o tomar como se dice
vulgarmente el toro por los cuernos y
decir no no tiene que sexual izar a la
mujer en la calle por cómo va vestida o
simplemente por el hecho de ser mujer
porque tampoco nos digamos mentiras
lucía la falda no es necesaria para que
una mujer sufra acoso callejero es
totalmente cierto no importa cuánta es
vestida de todas formas algún momento o
alguna persona o algún hombre te va a
querer decir algo
con respecto a ese pedazo de la canción
es muy importante decir que nosotros
también que hicimos como mezclar letras
de otras canciones entonces hay una
canción que se volvió muy viral que es
así arrebata dando vuelta en la jeepeta
y dice como lo mío tiene una rubia que
tiene
los zetas y quiere que se lo meta
entonces nosotras decimos todo lo
contrario en la canción como también
darle una reivindicación a este tipo de
letras porque por supuesto los cantantes
de la música no es que estén mal o
debamos cancelar los ellos simplemente
son un espejo y son un significado de
lo que nosotros estamos haciendo
realmente lo que en la vida real está
sucediendo entonces ellos son como el
reflejo por esa razón una canción pues
simplemente está mostrando culturalmente
lo que está sucediendo
pues muchísimas gracias a ustedes lucia
beltrán chamorro la mona soy yo y para
del cierre simplemente quiero citar una
parte de su canción y es que sin pero no
hay revolución gracias por estar con
nosotros ya nuestros televidentes nos
vemos próximamente en ella soy
[Música]